Speaker 1: Fox News is continuing its careful
but very clear praise and glorification campaign
of Ron DeSantis. Remember that Fox News
would prefer someone other than Trump be
nominee. They would seemingly prefer it
to be Ron DeSantis, but they're going to
try to keep Trump sort of in their orbit so that
whoever is ultimately the nominee, they maintain
access and can do interviews and whatever the
case may be. But the propaganda campaign for
DeSantis continues. The latest clip. Very hard
hitting is Fox and Friends host Brian KILMEADE.
Flies out to play catch with Ron DeSantis while
he interviews him. It's an interview while playing
catch, and if you're just listening to this,
you will notice a couple of things. You will
be hearing a healthy THWACK. That THWACK
is the that's a tough word to say for me,
that THWACK is the ball hitting the
baseball gloves. And you will notice
that Ron DeSantis lacks charisma, which you
probably already knew. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Time to run for president. Would you
think at some time it's safe to say that that
would be one of your goals? I would. I would
only I would only do stuff if I thought there
was a rationale for me to accomplish things on
behalf of the people. So it's all substance driven
about whether I could serve or not serve.
Oh, yeah. Capacities. But I'll tell you,
you know that as governor and if you're a
determined executive, you know, you can make
things happen. And we've done that in Florida.
What can we expect to be announced? Depends how
good we do in this legislative session.
Speaker 1: What a charismatic guy,
huh? So a couple different things. One,
I like the idea of playing catch during
an interview. And I would like the opportunity
to either be interviewed or interview someone
while playing catch. I have to hand it to Brian
KILMEADE. It's actually quite an idea. Obviously,
it's completely vapid when it comes to the
context, which is this is all just propaganda puff
piece stuff for Ron DeSantis. But also there is no
scenario, no matter how friendly in which DeSantis
comes off looking like a charismatic guy. That's
another thing that we're quickly learning. Now,
last week, Brian KILMEADE was also in Florida.
This was on March 8th, so six days ago. And he
did one of these things where he goes to a diner
in Tampa and it didn't go super well in terms of
this DeSantis campaign, because even in Florida,
a lot of the people that KILMEADE spoke to were
showing more enthusiasm for Donald Trump. Take a.
Speaker 2: Look. What's special about this place?
What's special about Tampa Bay? Just so
you know, DeSantis is a great governor.
He allows us to freedom to be able to do what
we like to do and no taxation. So it's a great
place to live. All right. So tell me, what
attracted you to this lovely, handsome man 60
years ago? He was good looking. And he is.
Speaker 8: Yes, he is. And he was funny.
Speaker 2: A little humor can get you a
long way, right? Let me just tell you,
he's still funny right now. Okay. Let
me go over here if I can. So what's your
name? Peter Shatner. Peter Shatner. Why was it a.
Speaker 1: Totally random interview, by the way.
Speaker 2: For you to wear this jacket that
screams Florida and come down here an hour
before this opened to be on our show? Because I'm
going to direct traffic later. What issue matters
most to you? Oh, you mean generally now? Right
now, I think we have a problem in this country.
I think we need new management.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, you guys,
what issue matters most to you? Well, we've
got a problem in this country. Oh, yeah, but
the interesting point. Yeah. How do you suggest
just fixing it? Well, just change the management.
Speaker 2: I hope that Trump runs the
course and wins, but we'll see what happens.
All right. How many people here want Trump
to run? How many people want Trump to win?
Okay. All right. We're going to have more from
everybody. We'll get everybody's opinions here
this morning. It's a great breakfast place.
I'm so glad you're up. Let's go either to
break. In fact, I want to go to Ainsley.
Speaker 8: Ron DeSantis, watch this to run.
Speaker 2: All right. Anyway,
so then they you know as we.
Speaker 1: We are then this is a montage
with the baseball clip. So, listen,
I do think that Fox News is trying to thread a
very particular needle here. They are exposed by
these recent text messages as widely not believing
Trump's election lies and also disliking Trump
per Tucker Carlson's own text messages. And
they want to maintain access to Trump, but
they'd also rather it be someone else. The only
problem is the horse. It's a very uncharismatic
horse that they seem to be trying to ride. And
we will see where that goes. And by the way,
speaking of lack of charisma, let's talk about
the new word that Ron DeSantis is now floating.